YELENA:
I tell people my sister
moved out west.
♪♪
YELENA:
You’re a science teacher.
Your husband...
he renovates houses.
YELENA:
You’re thinking about moving
but you’re gonna
wait until
the interest rates
go down.
NATASHA:
That’s not my story.
[NATASHA laughs]
♪♪
NATASHA:
Before I was an Avenger...
...I made
mistakes...
...and a lot
of enemies.
YELENA:
His call sign’s Taskmasker.
He controls the Red Room.
YELENA:
They’re manipulated...
...fully conscious,
but no choices.
NATASHA:
I should have come back for you.
How many others
are there?
YELENA:
Enough.
[Drumming intensifies]
♪♪
NATASHA:
We have to go back
to where it
all started...
...so they never do
that to anyone again.
ALEXEI:
We are family...
we fight with you.
MELINA:
You won’t win.
I always found it best...
...not to look
into the past.
YELENA:
Okay, you got a plan
or shall I just stay,
duck, and cover?
NATASHA:
My plan was to drive us away!
YELENA:
Well, your plan sucks.
♪♪
NATASHA:
At some point we all
have to
choose...
...between what the world
wants you to be...
...and who
you are.
[Drums intensify]
[Heavy gunfire]
NATASHA:
I made my choice...
...I’m done running.
♪♪
YELENA:
Woo!
♪♪
NATASHA:
Here’s what’s gonna happen...
MELINA:
Natasha, don’t slouch.
NATASHA:
I'm not slouching.
MELINA:
You’re going to get the back hunch.
ALEXEI:
Hm, listen to your mother.
NATASHA:
Oh my God this...
ALEXEI:
Up, up!
NATASHA:
Alright, enough. All of you.
YELENA:
I didn’t say anything,
that’s not fair.
♪♪